اوكرانيا حيث يبدو ان ميدان المعركه في
الاشهر القادمه سيشهد اشد مراحل الحظ
دراوى فلا صوت يعلو على الرصاص وسط جنود
يسود ساحه الحرب حاليا ضربات روسيا مكثفات
دون اي رد اوكرانيا فيما يبقى السؤال الذي
طرحته صحيفه جاردن البريطانيه من سيضرب
اولا واين الجانبان في الوقت الحالي بحسب
الصحيفه ينشغلان بتعزيز دفاعتهما وحشت
قوتهما استعدادا لاي هجوم محتملا من جبهات
الحرب حيث تعمل روسي على تقويه قوتها مع
مساعد رئيس الروسي الذي يفوتن من اجل
الانتاج الدبابات وصواريخ جديده محللون
راوا ان خطوه لكريم بتكليف بلا رجيموف
للاشراف المباشر عن العمليات الاوكرانيه
تنظر باستعداد موسكو للشني هجوم كبير
خصوصا بعد ان انتهت المرحله الاولى من
الحرب بخسائر كبيره في الشمال وفي حركات
واخرسانه في صفوف الروس وفقا للجارديان